has spent the better part of her morning
looking for water at a village in tukana
County
she and other women have dark shell
Wells but these pools of water are
getting drier
the water is getting dirtier and
dangerous because of the alkaline levels
she's seven months pregnant and every
day it's becoming more difficult for her
to walk the distance
we have to dig deep to get water our
children get sick often some of the
boreholes provided by the government
have run dry some parts have broken down
government and other Aid agencies are
worried they say they're facing a state
of emergency the population is currently
depending on
the boreholes and the hand that was the
depth of the hand that was actually
going farther down
Beyond five meters in some areas
others actually up to seven meters and
for the population itself it's actually
very dangerous because there is likely
likelihood of collapsing of walls there
is a drought in much of the Horn of
Africa millions of people are on the
brink of starvation four rainy seasons
have failed whether experts predict
another fail this year
this Harding Community is resilient and
proud many of them have lost most of
their livestock
now they have to rely on relief Foods
on this day they waited for hours in the
sweltering hits for Aid
politicians who had brought the food
arrived late everyone was tired thirsty
and hungry people are receiving Maize
beans and cooking oil but this food does
not come often and Villages that we are
talking to say it's not even enough
children in The Villages are
malnourished many live far from Health
Centers
doctors at this government Hospital say
some children come when they are already
too weak to save them these children
after treatment they understand they go
home the status at home has not changed
So within two months
over 20 percent
come back
so there's a relapse
back at the Village the women finally
get their cereals they say the food is
hardly enough but at least it will keep
the little ones alive as a parents
figure out where they will get the next
meal Catherine soy Al Jazeera tukana
County in Northern Kenya